الان مشاهدينا الى كوريا الشماليه ومحاوله
فاشله لاطلاق قمر اصطناعي للتجسس تسببت في
حاله ارتباك في كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
وردود فعل غاضبه فما الذي حدث
قلت وكاله الانباء الكوريه الشماليه
الرسميه ان الصاروخ الفضائيه الجديد
تشيولينا واحد تحضن في البحر الغربي وهو
الاسم الكوري للبحر الاصفر مبرره هذا
الفشل بعدم استقرار المحرك ونظام الوقود
واعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان المقذوف
الكوريه الشماليه اختفى من على شاشات
الرادار قبل ان يصل الى نقطه سقوطه
المتوقع ونشر الجيش الكوري الجنوبي صورا
لانتشال حطام قمر الاستطلاع الاصطناعي
العسكري من البحر على بعد 200 كيلومتر غرب
جزيره ايو شيونج التي تقع قباله الساحل
الغربي لكوريا الجنوبيه ما حدث في السعه
الاخيره يعد سادس محاولات بيونج لاطلاق
قمر صناعي والاولى لها منذ عام 2016 كان
من المفترض ان تضع اول قمر صناعي للتجسس
تطلقه كوريا الشماليه في مداره تسببت
المحاوله الفاشله لاطلاق كوريا الشماليه
قمرا صناعيا عسكريا تسبب في اطلاق صافرات
الانذار في انحاء سول كافه في وقت مبكر من
الصباح كما اصدرت الحكومه اليابانيه تحذ
يرا طارئا لسكان مقاطعه اوكينا والجنوبيه
وطلبت منهم الاحتماء داخل منازلهم
عموما
المحاوله الكوريه الشماليه الفاشله سلطت
الضوء مجددا على الفروق بين تقنيه
المستخدمه في كل من عمليات اطلاق الاقمار
الصناعيه والصواريخ الباليسيه العابره
للقارات
يتطلب ارسال الاقمار الاصطناعيه الى
الفضاء واطلاق الصواريخ الباليسيه العابره
للقارات هندسه خاصه بالصواريخ كما يحتاج
لخبره متطوره كما يقول الخبراء
تحمل صواريخ الباليسيه انظمه توجيه داخليه
تسمح لها بمغادره الغلاف الجوي ثم دخوله
لضرب اهداف محدده على الارض عندما يطلق
قمر اصطناعي ينقله الصاروخ الى مدار معين
ثم ينفصل عنه ويسقط على الارض او في البحر
على شكل وابل من الحطام
يقول خبراء انه فيما يتعلق بالصواريخ
الباليسير عابره للقارات فان اتقان تقنيات
اعاده الدخول الى الغلاف الجوي امر ضروري
بضمان عدم احتراق راس حربيه قبل بلوغ
هدفها ولكن بالنسبه الى صواريخ التي تحمل
اقمرا اصطناعيه فان هذا النوع من
التكنولوجيا التي تسمح بدخول الغلاف الجوي
ليس ضروريا وفي الاخير يشير المحللون الى
ان الاختبار الذي اجري الاربعاء يظهر رغبه
كوريا الشماليه في دخول عصر الفضاء
العسكري قبل جارتها الجنوبيه والمتوقع ان
تطلق اول قمر اصطناعي مخصص فقط للتطبيقات
العسكريه بحلول نهايه العام وذلك بواسطه
صاروخ سبيس